we've got new reporting on Kate and
Megan's relationship today is Daddy
Prince Harry steps into the ring
[Music]
a solo Harry got ready to rumble at a
youth sports center he seemed to have a
good time with the boxers Megan won't be
joining him on many royal outings for a
while my palace sources tell me not to
expect Megan to return to work full-time
until the fall when we're expecting the
couple to undertake a tour of South
Africa baby Archie is expected to be on
board for that African visit in other
royal news Kate and William were out
together both learning how to share
sheep over the weekend we couldn't help
but notice Kate and Megan having a
friendly looking chat in that carriage
could they be bonding over babies I hear
that Kate has made herself available to
Megan if if she needs advice if she
needs any help then Kate said to her I'm
here for you
so has Archie's birth put an end to that
fab 4 viewed for a while things were
pretty tense between William and Harry
it's absolutely the case that the
brothers did fall out I was told by a
very senior royal source that actually
they weren't talking to each other at
one point I certainly think now that
Archie is here it has probably really
helped to improve the relationship
William is over the moon that his
brother is a dad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]